we are very excited to announce support
for the display of data in the UCSC
track hub for bet as a new feature of
ncbi's genome browser gdv the genome
data viewer we've added a track hubs
option to the user data widget
here you can input an own track hub URL
or search the track hub registry a
resource based at the MBL EBI I'll
search for gencode you see the number of
hubs in the results and the number of
tracks per hub selecting a hub initiates
the connection and clicking the arrow
expands the track selection menu for
this hub notice that this hub has data
for mouse as well as human I'll select a
track representing a bigwig file
and another for a big bed file you can
recognize the tracks that come from
sources external to NCBI like these
track hubs by the green highlight in
their label the widget offers a summary
of the tracks and you can return to
configure to refine your choices or
explore the same hub in another organism
such as mouse you can also configure
track ups in the viewers tracks menu
please give this new feature a try and
we'd love to hear your feedback and
questions
for additional details about the feature
check out the help documentation linked
near the top right of the gdv home page